michael shea moule est avec nous merci
d'être là mickaël vous avez 57 ans vous
avez donc été le schoder le chauffeur
d'harvey weinstein de 2008 à 2013 lors
du festival de cannes vous ne le suive y
est que pendant le festival de cannes
c'est que pendant que celle des trains
il faut pas confondre que avec 6 en 365
jours sur 365 jours c'est ça donc on va
prendre un jour vous étiez avec moi là
une même dix jours de semaine on va dire
vous savez le et toujours c'est toujours
vous qui prenez absolument d'accord très
bien alors vous avez fait un burn-out
après avoir travaillé pour lui puis une
dépression mais vous avez fait une
dépression en travaillant dix jours à
quelqu'un vous avez fait une dépression
même si c'était que dix jours par an
voilà ça c'est intense ah oui on va
travailler avec la weinstein entre 16 et
18 heures par jour ça équivaut on est on
va dire six mois de boulot alors vous
n'étiez pas seulement son chauffeur
pendant ces dix jours vous étiez vous
dites son homme à tout faire au début du
livre vous écrivez quelques lignes pour
décrire donc votre position par rapport
à vendenheim et vous dites plus que son
chauffeur donc j'ai été son homme à tout
faire qui régler les questions vitales
et les petits riens du quotidien
malgré ses mauvaises manières malgré sa
folie je le servait il m'intriguait son
génie m'impressionner les facettes du
septième art tourbillonner entre ses
mains comme une toupie dans la paume
d'un illusionniste
au début ça se passait bien avec lui
très très bien c'était l'ange blanche
que tout le monde de la juge est
d'accord tout le monde se prosternaient
ses pieds et il avait une ascension
fulgurante justement aaa à l'époque
qu'en 2008 jusqu'en 2013
là on a en a sur une un personnage assez
assez a changé eh bien il s'est
transformé en dément progresser ce que
vous dites vous dites dont voici le
portrait d'un orgue honda nobre sexuelle
d'un monstre moral d'un cyclope sorti
tout droit des temps archaïques
il n'a qu'un oeil celui de la bestialité
et il se fout de la décence mme allende
on a on appris des huit meilleurs
passages du livre et on va vous faire
des révélations vous allez voir c'est
incroyable ce que vous dites vous évoqué
au début du livre une mallette argentier
qui accompagne harvey partout vous vous
dites qu'elle contient des contrats met
à la page 177 vous comprenez qu'elle
contient totalement autre chose puisque
cette mallette argenté est restée
entrouverte un joint et vous vous rendez
compte qu'elle était pleine de coire a
écouté c'est simple quand je vois une
malade
surtout celle d'hervé entrouverte avec
des objets sexuels donc des sextos
risque les accessoires des préservatifs
des pulls translucide en fait il y avait
des pastilles des comprimés vie d'aller
jusqu'au fond j'ai tout de suite compris
je leur fermer parce que j'avais compris
un truc qui m'avait choqué à ce moment
là et ça c'était la quatrième et
cinquième années c'était vraiment vers
la fin et je portais cette mallette pas
mal de temps à chaque fois qu'ils
venaient maïmouna confié jeune homme
était dans le coffre
michael kael ça c'est très important
cette planète il ya tous mes papiers
dedans y'a mon passeport et bancaires de
crédit en fait qui avait pour vous il y
avait des sextoys des accessoires déjà
sur ce premier passage eric naulleau
vous sur le lit vous l'avez lu le livre
de michaël schemoul le démon de la
croisette où vous le dites quoi jeudi
c'est un livre qui me dérange parce que
je ne sais pas par qui il a été écrit
est ce qu'il a été écrit par un témoin
est ce qu'il a été écrit par une victime
parce qu'il finit par vous frapper ou
est ce qu'il a été écrit par un complice
voilà nom et comme je ne sais pas je
disais la semaine dernière que quand
quelqu'un vient témoigner d'une
souffrance et catherine laborde et que
c'est un beau livre vraiment j'adore
même littérairement là c'est l'autre
catégorie c'est le côté négatif c'est
l'anti catherine laborde
c'est à dire que la démarche me dérange
déjà le livre me dérange parce que je me
dis que si vraiment tout ça s'est passé
je n'ai pas votre parole en doute mais
vous auriez dû arrêter plus tôt et même
le dénoncer je prends cet homme oui mais
mettez-vous à la place du chauffeur de
grande remise
j'ai pas le permis de conduire j'ai très
bien pris deux semaines avant mais qu'at
elle vous étiez très bien payé j'étais
bien payé mais j'étais payé vous savez
ils avaient des véhicules de luxe dont
il y avait des débats qui est d'aimer
bac savoir c'est qu'il n'était pas avec
ma fiesta voilà donc où einstein il
roulait en six ans mercedes vont bien
vous touchez pour les dix jours
dans les 3000 euros ouais c'est non donc
voilà je faisais dix huit jours d'accord
vous avez un double salaire donc il
voulait pas de tête différents niveaux
de la marque au fer alors vous avez
acheté votre silence pour 3 me en même
temps après non pas du tout pas du tout
parce que là on part dans dans la
dogmatique quand on rentre dans ce sujet
moi je pense que quand j'ai commencé par
conduire à verisign
c'était un ange pour moi quelqu'un qui
arrive et qui était adulé une chance
pour vous mais c'était mais je t'ai fier
j'étais fier de conduire alors chaîne
vous dit dans le livre que des ragots
prétendait que des chauffeurs c'est le
septième me voilà c'est un autre passage
qu'on a pris puisque on va dérouler les
huit passages les plus forts vous dites
des ragots prétendait que des chauffeurs
qui s'était plié à ses caprices dans les
années 90 avait fini comme punching ball
du producteur quand il avait transgressé
le code weinstein il les faisait se
mettre à genoux sur le crâne de son le
gravier d'un parking désert et les giflé
à répétition avec ses grosses paluches
d'obèses
à quel moment vous avez commencé à vous
rendre compte qu'ils avaient des
agissements bizarres avec vous ce qui
s'est passé des trucs bizarres au départ
c'est à dire que bon progressivement on
commence à rentrer dans cette intimité
sans être son ami donc on est on est on
est le chauffeur on est la pièce
maîtresse qui véhicule le monstre sacré
du cinéma à cette époque
et puis vous rendez compte que il un
langage qui de rungis quoi il est un
gage d'un poissonnier gérer les moments
chauds je veux dire mais je dire la
criée quoi je veux dire c'est un type
qui avait la voix qui porte et pour la
ductilité autoritaire quand il parlait
il vous faisait peur oui il m'a
impressionné
en fait j'étais complètement scotché
devant le phénomène donc je me tais dit
owni qu'elle soit zen fait ton boulot et
puis et puis tu avec le meilleur qu'on
va on va revenir dans un à la tendance
sur dans le livre est ce parce que vous
avez vu est ce que vous avez pu suivre
dans la voiture où ce qui se passait
dans la voiture ou bien il ya des scènes
que vous décrivez qui sont complètement
folle à gâteau vous vouliez dire quelque
chose sur ligne oui alors moi je me suis
retrouvé à batailler avec des sentiments
personnels assez mitigé à la lecture de
votre livre
parce qu'évidemment vous décrivez donc
des comportements odieux des situations
aberrantes
mais en fait on sait que c'est une
sombre merde se met maintenant don
meehan on n'a jamais eu des roannais
vu qu'on sait on sait que c'est un
connard fini depuis octobre et le 17 des
actrices et des femmes prennent la
parole pour dénoncer ces agissements
quelques uns c'est violer abuser donc
j'ai juste une tâche est juste une
question de l'intérieur c'est juste une
question pourquoi au moment où les
langues de ces femmes se sont déliées
vous n'avez pas pris la parole à ce
moment là et pourquoi attendre un an et
vous je peux après un an et demi moi
j'ai commencé le livre par une thérapie
avec un psychiatre qui me conseillez de
2,2 d'extirper ce qui ce qui était ancré
en moi aura amené au filtre et à qui je
suis rentré dans une dépression nerveuse
vous savez quand vous avez une claque un
coup de poing et un coup de coude dans
les côtes ont connu un rush time pour
une raison on va on va revenir sur ce
qu'il voit là et donc donc à partir du
moment où vous déposez plainte et que
cette plainte vient casser sans suite
c'est vrai que ça ça vous laisse sur une
situation complètement chaotique
alors il ya un autre passage qu'on a
choisi c'est vous dites un moment
j'entends un plongeon à l'eau et comme
des clapotement fuck you j'ai
l'impression card et a ajouté josh par
dessus bord c'est un de ses employés
avec son téléphone bruno venait de
déposer harvey au majestic
les secours arrivés le jeune homme était
en état de choc et un second passage
avec sa femme qui ne voulait pas emmener
une soirée qui était pour lui une soirée
apparemment business
puis il demande une m'ordonne de stopper
la voiture sur le bas côté
il descend et se met à massacrer le
capot avec ses grosses mains puis c'est
le rétroviseur il s'attaque aux pneus en
donnant des coups de pieds de tout son
poids
enfin il se met à rouler je suis là pour
mon business c'est super important
sa femme finit par s'incliner il a eu
gain de cause ça c'est un d un des
nombreux passages
voilà vous dites aussi il ya un passage
incroyable vous révéler que le même la
propre femme d'harvey weinstein georgina
chapman ramener des filles à son mari ça
c'est fou vous dites la sincérité
m'oblige à dire que c'est aussi son arme
fatale pour lever des pin up et d'une
façon tellement naturel que même
georgina devient inconsciemment ça
rabatteuse elle ira jusqu'à baratiner
elles mêmes défis par fierté pour son
mari producteur et pour lui permettre de
faire de grands films oui et karim
zéribi et vous lire
non moi ce livre je vais trouver
doublement choquant d'abord choquant
parce qu'on a une
une réalité qui est celle de l'intérieur
avec des révélations qui sont pas
simplement didactique mais on arrive à
mettre des images sur les actes de ce
monstre mais je suis choqué aussi par
ailleurs parce que j'ai l'impression que
non seulement c'était un monstre avec la
gente féminine
mais c'était rambo ou quoi michael ce
que je comprends pas michael
attention je ne jette pas l'opprobre je
ne je n'ai je ne je ne vous juge pas ne
le prenez pas comme ça non je vous parle
librement et une sincérité
vous êtes un gaillard quand même vous
n'êtes pas vous n'êtes pas petit vous
avez pas chétif
le gars il vous met des gifles et des
coups de poing vous réagissez pas sur le
moment
spontanément on se défend un an
premièrement deuxièmement que vous
décrivez une scène dans le livre que
j'ai lu depuis un moment donné sur la
banquette arrière quasiment vous
assistez un viol alors on va en parler
la femme et la fille la firme vient
goutte c'est à dire comme vous le dites
si c'est un viol ça arrive d'avions va
en parler non mais ce que je veux vous
dire parce que ces deux moments je me
suis demandé mais michael pourquoi il
réagit pas alors je vais vous dire on va
recycler en temps mais on va revenir on
va revenir sur ce passage et c'est vrai
que c'est important la question de
karine pourquoi vous ne réagissez pas
parce que vous savez comme vous êtes
chauffeur de grande remise vous êtes
tenus par un secret professionnel qui
est dans le contrat de travail
cette année-là bon c'est une des
premières années que j'ai commencé
j'étais un employé damien vous frappe de
vingt-cinq réprouvé rotin logis se
défend quand on est victime quand avez
vous votre il faut pas jouer au malin ni
moi j'encaisse des coûts j'encaisse
parce que pourquoi parce que je veux
savoir jusqu'où il peut aller à vous
n'êtes pas payé près de frapper at du
tout pas du tout mais j'ai stoppé net
à partir du moment où il a levé la main
sur moi et si vous avez bien lu le livre
je le raconte très très bien je leur
décris j'explique que je lui ai parlé
d'homme à homme
après ces coups parce qu'il faut il faut
vivre ce moment avant de
il faut comprendre avant de commencer à
critiquer je les ai dit tu n'es pas ni
mon boss nylon bon dieu tu es juste un
client et je suis ton prestataires de
service et vous avez battu et a
travaillé avec l'actuel intérêts de
tenir à carreau d'abord ce mets ta
ceinture qu'il mettait jamais sa
ceinture et je te ramène au big boss et
si tu falt avec encore avec moi c'est
tous les deux qu'on va aller dans des
corps
après de là à lui rétorqué des coups je
suis capable bien sûr mais mais vous
savez la déontologie moi je suis pas un
garçon bagarreur d'anthologie il avait
une trop basse et depuis l'honneur lui
regarde vers passé lui c'est peut-être
michael c'est vous c'est votre opinion
au logis du secret professionnel il yal
assistance à personne en danger
mais peut on va revenir sur les passages
qui a eu 20 chauffeurs avant moi mais
qu'est un des autres chauffeurs la
frappe est peut-être mais quelle on va
revenir sur les autres passages que vous
en parlez là sans dire vraiment ce que
c'est parce que il ya un autre truc qui
est très choquant c'est vous dire vous
dites que des stars du cinéma étaient
complices on a choisi le passage où vous
relater une conversation téléphonique
entre harvey weinstein et a prénommé ben
après je vous dirai qui et apparemment
le prénommé ben et c'est incroyable de
le dévoiler dans le livre vous dites je
viens avec deux blocs 2 top model qui
rêve de faire du cinoche
j'ai promis que j'allais te présenter
que tu t'occupes reydel pour leur
trouver un rôle dans ton nouveau film
avec tarantino tu sais django unchained
elles sont comme des folles depuis elle
mouille dans leur culotte
bien jouer c'est amène les mois c'est
beach que je vois un peu ce qu'elles
savent faire ça c'est la réponse
d'harvey weinstein et semaine ce serait
un très grand acteur américain c'est un
affleck n'a rien à voir avec ça rien à
voir c'est un bel essai les bains c'est
comme les dupont est aux etats unis ces
valeurs accor va mettre des noms sur sur
les têtes parce que moi je mets mes
personnages dans le livre je les protège
et je me protège alors parce que ya ben
affleck avait mis mine de rien à tout le
soutien à ben stein lorsque il son
affaire et le scandale avait éclaté la
limite je suis attristé et en colère
qu'un homme avec qui j'ai travaillé et
utilisé son puissant statut pour
intimider sexuellement harcelés et
manipule autant de femmes pendant des
décennies les nouvelles accusations
d'agression que j'ai lu ce matin mauron
du malade alors qu'avant il avait posté
un tweet de soutien qu'il a supprimée et
ensuite il a remplacé par ce tweet alors
eu donc alors c'est alors que l'actrice
rose mcgowan l'une des victimes d'
harvey weinstein lui avait répondu hein
ben affleck va te faire [ __ ]
elle sous-entend évidemment que ben
affleck était au courant de toutes ces
agissements et ses histoires à effet un
second boss dans la sphère weinstein en
octobre dernier
puisque tout le monde dit tout le monde
était donc au courant que ben affleck
était lié avec stern
mais personne ne connaissait la
conversation que raconte mickey
dans son livre alors michael alors il ya
plein de choses j'aurais convient déjà
sur les passes accueillir près vous
allez réagir
une petite parenthèse on parlait du viol
qui s'est passé dans la voiture à
l'arrière et là je voudrais juste parler
de ça vous dit vous prononcez le mot
viol
votre conscience donc commencé à être
malmenées vous dites il est sûrement en
train de forcer la fille non il est sans
doute en train de la violer je suis très
mal oui pendant cette scène j'ai reculé
laisser la portière ouverte que faire
myriam me tuerait si elle apprenait que
j'ai été le témoin passif d'un viol
myriam c'est dans votre dans les loges
voilà exactement c'est votre réponse à
l'heure est à la page 166 vous raconter
une scène traumatisante pour vous une
fillette alors aux côtés d' harvey
weinstein à l'arrière de votre berline
vous raconter la fille lui demande de ne
pas lui faire mal
c'est un désastre il ne respecte
personne le [ __ ] sa grosse masse agite
un moment sur la blanc sur la banquette
une fellation dans ma voiture j'ai envie
de gerber c'est la première fois que je
le vois se comporter de cette façon
son visage de malades du sexe alors à ce
moment là pourquoi vous avez continué
travailler pour lui c'est la question
que tout le monde se pose et
téléspectateurs aussi on arrive on
arrive à la fin là on arrive à la balle
arrive avant avant le les coûts donc ça
laisse à désirer c'est à dire que bon je
rentre dans une histoire où je commence
à avoir les choses plus clairement
et puis après vous savez quand vous
parlez de viol mois en aucun cas j'ai
vues si vous voulez un manquement au
consentement
mais si longtemps par les donneurs je
veux dire mais mais mais mais vous savez
que les victimes étaient consentantes
quelque part parce qu'elles n'étaient
pas forcés silence est donc ça peut vous
savez dans le consentement il peut y
avoir violent aussi savez ça peut ça il
ya des dérapages au silence après il ya
la violence qui ne s'était pas c'était
pas un manche
ce n'était pas un enfant de choeur donc
peut-être qu'il lui fallait des
artifices un peu spéciaux peut-être que
la finale était avait pas l'habitude de
faire tu lui demander ce que l'exigé
d'elle après elle revient et elle va
dans ses bureaux de production signé le
contrat
donc qu'est ce que vous pouvez dire dans
tout ça vous allez qualifier ça de viol
et que vous été témoin c'est vous
je vais regarder mais je suppose que
mickey je mets entre parenthèses son cas
il est peut-être en train de la violer
non mais on fait quand je revois revenir
la fille qui dirait l'ami kane en bout
juge pas si l on veut jouer à nous dire
il me faisait peur vous pouvez le dire a
dit médina baye tous les jours avec
cette peur au ventre parce que on était
plombé ce cette omerta et vous savez moi
j'ai écrit ce livre pour peu pour savoir
comment nous tous
1 nous avions nous avions laissé faire
ce monstre est loin alors alors le
partage en plus impressionnant nous
aveugler nous avions nous avions nous
avions cette espèce de deux phénomènes
si vous voulez hypnotique qui faisait
qu'on avait un voile vient se poser sur
nous en avons tué les cinq jours ça
passait comme une flèche syndrome de
stockholm en fait vous êtes des admiriez
vous aimiez ou en avaient le syndrome de
stockholm vous admiriez on avait des
liens que j'avais une autre bourreau
mais quelle mais quelle justice genre
est concerné pas eu de vrai qu'on
parvienne sur l'un des passages les plus
impressionnants du livre il suivant elle
crie elle se débat ses mains agrippe la
vitre dégoulinant de l'humilité elle
s'agite dans tous les sens pour se
dégager mais rien n'arrête harvey qui
est tous ces plaintes en lui claquant la
bouche contre les sièges en cuir froid
il a dit qu'on n'avait pas assisté un
violent l'a quand même là c'est illumos
les fesses déchire sa culotte se
déchaîne sur elle je ne sais pas quoi
faire brusquement l'une des portières
s'ouvrent et la fille jeanne elle
vocifère à l'adresse d'harvey salle gros
con vieux sadique
j'espère que tu détiendra au moins ta
promesse deux années plus tard en
regardant la cérémonie des oscars j'ai
reconnu cette actrice brandissant une
statuette sous une pluie
d'applaudissements
voilà je serai pas les noms parce que se
reconnaîtront dans le lycée c'est fou ça
c'est passage c'est le passage le plus
impressionnant de vivre avec le jour où
il a il a levé la main sur roues
puisqu'il sûr il a porté en portant ma
main en portant sa main un mage ou leur
gueule le portant mama mama joue le
regard nerveux je lui demande comment il
peut lever la main sur moi sommes nous
revenus au temps de l'esclavagé c'est
bien la première fois depuis que je le
conduis qu'il tente un tel geste
puisqu'il a essayé de vous frapper
on nous a asséné un coup de coude d'une
violence inouïe dans les coteaux
l'impression pour monsieur chez lola
la limite c'est sa propre père sa
souffrance physique et pas celle des
autres donc moi je reste je marche je
vous faisais la région la première je
perds je veux pas tomber ce chiffre est
louée loin de là moi j'allais entraîner
des colosses et les grands costauds plus
que vous et c'est je me les j'imagine à
votre place il est mort le mec il est
mort le mec mais vous savez wilson qui
s'appelle il est des faux nez c'est moi
je vais fracasser la transversale et
justement
justement c'est vraiment cinq milieux de
j'avais à dire de merde excusez moi où
sont les valeurs cnmv sinon laissez pas
quelque chose qu'on dit c'est que je te
donne pas les moyens je tatoue moi j'ai
joué avec ses serments et c'est pas
méchant
je voudrais que de faibles rentrées
l'admirer j'étais ok de l'avenir
il te met des coups des deux coups de
poing dans l'écho en tout cas ce qu'a
dit au massacre mais tu m'excuses mais
alors sur l'acceptent sa bombe à weston
cambridge on en a rien à cirer
oui mais faudrait-il qu'elle s'est pas
été facile j'ai compris je le comprends
mais c'est là que je dis moi c'est pas
quelque chose que je fais où il
apprendra géraldine alors moi je vous
trouve monsieur à la fois extrêmement
courageux de venir témoigner de faire le
livre de sur cuir de vous-même pour
pouvoir témoigner de ce que vous avez vu
on sent que ça vaut un traumatisme
premières notes chapeau bas respect
votre première télé en plus ça balance
ton post bravo après ensuite
ensuite c'est vrai qu'on peut se poser
la question ne nous trompons pas de
coupable ne nous trompons pas de
coupable c'est parce qu'on veut dire en
revanche c'est vrai que lorsqu'on voit
ça que vous témoignez sa dont le
désormais pourquoi il n'a pas sauvé
cette fille est peut-être
qu'effectivement vous posez de poser la
question est ce que je comprends et on
comprend qu'après ce livre là vous et
salvateur et vous aguerris et vous aide
à mieux comprendre même ce qui s'est
passé après et vous n'êtes pas encore et
ça ce centre n'est pas encore guéri mais
c'est vrai qu'on peut se poser la
question mais pourquoi ça sera votre
fille qu'est ce que vous avez fait voilà
la question que vous êtes pour la
gestion mais je n'ai pas d'enfants mais
j'ai deux le choc avons rempli est ce
que beaucoup de papier didier ou pas
complètement il explique dans le livre à
la rigueur je culpabilise à bloc
et puis je suis un garçon
je suis originaire d'alger donc je la
tamise obligatoires alors je rappelle
qu'il est donneur d'alger où on a du mal
de parler à bas historique d'aller semer
justifier devant cette situation très
critique comme l impression que vous
deux vous savez pourquoi les gens
peuvent s'interroger aujourd'hui parce
qu'on a le sentiment que vous livrer
votre part de vérité
une fois que tout est sortie ça du tout
est donc conseillé de naming
c'est ça que tout le monde il était
traumatisé
alors attendez attendez toc toc gynéco
qui viendront était quand même là bas
les pattes on peut dire c'est pas moi
par contre il a mangé de la charcuterie
alors voilà la question que moi je me
pose qui est c'est de savoir et de
comprendre comment et pourquoi vous avez
la chance vous monsieur d'avoir vraiment
côtoyer et bien ces gens que nous on
pense être les mieux éduqués dans le
monde et qui sont vraiment qu'ils
côtoient aussi les bdd des hommes d'état
et puis ils frisent il côtoie le gratin
de ce monde et des choses
extraordinaires ils sont dans les
endroits les plus merveilleux ils sont
au fait de des sciences des arts et de
la culture
cette meilleure quand vous votez oui
d'anticipation et son style est alors on
va dire bonjour doc
commença alors mais comment ils sont
arrivés là parce que nous non on disait
moi c'est quoi ces personnes là mais
quand est-ce que je vais aller au
festival n'avait pas des surhommes que
ces chocs le festival de cannes ça fait
rêver
là on voit là où la face sombre du
festival de cannes est peut-être voilà
comme vous disiez bernard du cinéma mais
ce que c'est que voilà géraldine vous
vous prenez la défense de deux mickey
mais moi j'ai aimé votre livre thérapie
j'ai trouvé sincère
alors évidemment on le lit avec un
certain voyeurisme un peu un peu gêné
comme si on lisait un voici trash et
pornographique
mais malgré tout même si vous avez tout
vu vous avez tout entendu vous avez
d'une certaine manière tout cautionné
par votre silence
moi j'ai eu un passage qui m'a
bouleversé dans le livre c'est quand
votre femme qui est au courant de tout
et de votre mal-être appel l'équipe de
wine chine et lui dit mais c'est pas
possible vous avaient tabassé mon mari
c'est pas possible si wayne chine a
tabassé mon mari et on lui répond ah
mais tu peux appeler la police l'armée
la marine nationale
si tu veux mais tu ne pourras jamais
rien faire contre lui sais tu qui est
qui et harvey weinstein est en fait on
lui raccroche au nez et en fait nous
rappellent trois fois de suite oui et
vous étiez détournant lise vous étiez
sous emprise sous influence et moi ce
syndrome de stockholm la me touche
beaucoup chez vous voilà oui mais voilà
il ya beaucoup de gens qui qui qui
critiquent son comprendre parce qu'il
faut comprendre d'abord avant de
critiquer avant de mettre une opinion
qui sera pas forcément la même que la
mienne
et puis après quand on rentre dans cette
dogmatique tranchante comme un couperet
comme la guillotine qui vous vient
dessus vous allaitez coupat vous avez
été complice basterds est resté six ans
à 6 ans que c'est pas vrai du tout je
suis resté deux semaines sûr étalée sur
six ans ça fait trois quatre mois en
cours sur le dos je n'aurais jamais pu
conduire avait en chine pendant un an
toute la noce temps tant de temps que ça
c'était impossible
dix jours c'était déjà la cible
il fallait le 4 5 jours pour récupérer
et quand il partait donc il vous est
toujours la même manière après la
violence physique est arrivé
progressivement après c'est vrai qu'il y
avait cette violence morale
il m'a bouffé mon cerveau c'est un beauf
d'énergie c'est un hypnotiseur c'est
messmer ses voiles a123 plus chez vous
un film spécial du film est commencé et
failli aller au fond du sujet il faut
comprendre pourquoi
après on peut facilement dire comme
certains internautes commentent ouais
c'est un gros tas de merde et mais
chalmé l'interpellant et ceci cela il
régnait comme lui c'est important mais
quelle est la dernière question que tout
le monde se pose est ce que vous avez
fait ce livre pour gagner des sous ou
est ce que vous l'avez fait qu'ils sont
vraiment pas bon voilà pour vous libérer
sincèrement sincèrement moi je veux
qu'on soit débarrassé de cette menace
qui qui perdure sur cette planète c'est
très grave parce que si j'ai écrit ce
livre c'est aussi mama mama mon opinion
va directement au mouvement mitu balance
son port et puis si ça peut aider
donc ça soit en utilité publique ça se
reproduit qu'il faudrait il faudrait
revoir les choses là dessus et puis
deuxième guérir aussi gémeaux guerrière
et javelot pour guérir si j'avais pas
parler aujourd'hui
personne n'aurait parlé de harvey
weinstein à cannes en coulisses est vrai
maintenant chauffeur avant moi ses deux
chauffeurs affirmant il ya eu un
historique j'ai été chercher tous ces
chauffeurs failles de leurs élargi aux
seuls amis escrime s'était raté pour lui
auditions des moyens c'est surtout ça
soit modus plus la queue entre les
jambes me raser les murs il me dit mais
tu sais quoi il ya une marraine avocat
me kane mais tu es fou quoi mais tu vas
morphée mettez tout le monde avec marjo
et et me voyez évolué avec lui j'étais
comme vous savez jim carrey est
aujourd'hui malade et plus peur je me
transforme et et puis il m'a dit m'a
complètement transformé ce mec qui m'a
j'étais plus le moins michael et je le
raconte si bien dans le dans le livre
c'est raté je suis en plein thérapie je
suis encore dans mon burn out et les
gens ne comprend toujours rien voilà je
suis désolé le démon de la croisette
michael chamoun merci michael d'abord
avec d'avoir été là
non la semaine merci michael merci
beaucoup